here's a reality let's bring it back to
the United States women live longer than
men this is a surveillance pre exclusive
women make less than men that's not
funny
it's a toxic cocktail for all of America
our failing retirement planning
we know that for women it's ever more
important the reality is women are
running out of money as they migrate to
87 his men migrate to somewhere in the
vicinity of 83
Sally Krawczyk has provided true
leadership on this debate and analysis
she's chair of elevate Network what is
your to-do list to help all of America
with his idea of what women need to do
because the retirement savings crisis is
trillions wide and it is so big and it's
so ugly we stopped actually talking
about it you don't hear the presidential
candidates talking about it if you put
in an overlay that women live longer
than men right it's actually a female
crisis it's actually a female crisis and
once you have that view I mean 80 85
percent of nursing home participants are
women 85% are women walk through a
nursing home and it's women all what
policy would you like to see for motion
well it's all about economic financial
engagement of women so if you start to
look at it that way a mandated paternal
leave is no longer pesky women having
pesky children it's an investment in the
enclosing the retirement savings gap
because with a mandated maternal leave
paternal leave you see that women stay
in the workforce longer the longer they
leave they have the more they come back
I feel like this has really come home to
my generation you know the the title 9
generation my wife works full-time I
work full-time and really these don't
feel like women's issues they feel like
family issues that we are both dealing
yea with due respect I mean you
gentlemen you know won't have the
retirement savings crisis to worry about
you'll be dead
so we're left with it and so how do you
solve it and keeping women in the work
force and my old business the wealth
management business helping women invest
more because women are under invested
versus men there's a gender investing
gap keeping them in the workforce
investing more mandated
ah parental leave those of this little
to both of you the employment retirement
income Securities Act of 1974 didn't see
this coming
what policy prescription what tax policy
prescription can help men and pesky
women or maybe asking men I mean the law
is a disaster just starting with Orszag
who wants opt in a 401k what policy
decision would you like to see from
President Clinton or President Trump the
first one that isn't being talked about
is is mandated parental leave we are the
only country in the world except for
Papua New Guinea that doesn't have one
it really is now weary sigh recently
surveyed the women of elevate network
the professional learning elevate
network 95% of them believe we should
have a mandated put parental leave you
can't get 95% of professional women to
agree on anything and they agree that
this can be an important way to close
that gap
I will sing in that choir I really I
can't say enough about nine dated
paternal leave Barry Eichengreen let's
let's take that and move it back to
Europe is it possible to look at what's
going on and see not a euro crisis but a
retirement crisis so much of this
argument with Greece centered around the
differentials between the way Estonia
handles its pensioners and the way
Greece handles its pension they have a
retirement crisis they have a
demographic crisis and they're much
older society than we are they have a
women's labor force participation crisis
in that participation rates remain lower
than in the United States so they have
all the same issues that we do they do
grant your parental leave but on all
other dimensions they have an even
bigger problem your textbook is
authoritative not your textbook but your
book Europe after the 1945 it's
absolutely authoritative on that
cultural shift in Europe what do you
perceive is the new Europe in Greece in
Germany and elsewhere different from
five years ago let alone 40 years ago
what's the behavioural difference the
Europeans are beginning to get their
minds around the fact that they have to
compete globally as well they don't want
Anglo Saxon cap
Oh Jerry Muller at Catholic University
as their going to be an anglo-saxon
Europe and I and I think the answer is
no the alternate alternatives of social
market economy and are simply too well
agree that professor Greeley you know I
will actually wanted to ask a slightly
different question which is when you
look at you know within Europe one of
the things that it explicitly is not as
a transfer Union but it does seem like
as you get movement of people within
Europe you have young people leaving
places like Bulgaria Greece Spain going
to Berlin they're not paying into their
own retirement funds back home so I mean
does does it need that kind of
retirement transfer at the very least
well it certainly needs a common pension
system and they're beginning to move in
that direction
and it needs to recognize I think that
migration in the American style creates
problems in Europe as well as solving
yeah very I'd be remiss if I didn't ask
you about gold you of the ownership of
the authoritative book on it golden
fetters from years ago gold breaking
down to new lows and new lows and new
lows does that signal global
disinflation and continued deflation
I think it's indication of continued low
flaky and the fact that there are plenty
of financial instruments out there that
substitute for gold and dominated you're
gonna say gold has lost its luster
having said that for 20 or so years I'll
keep saying it until I'm right jelly's
right as well